Being independent is not wanting the best for Catalonia.
For me,
being independent is as anti-Catalan as possible,
precisely
because since the beginning of the independence process
we have fared worse than ever.
The Catalan language is less spoken than it was 12 years ago.
What has independence done in Catalonia?
If today it is the Catalan language?
In the metropolitan area of barcelona
less is said than it was 10 years ago.
And in rural areas it is also happening.
Something wrong.
Is Catalan being born today?
You don't look the way it looked 15 or 20 years ago.
As of today
cataluña is not admired from abroad
nor from our neighbors as they were previously admired.
Investment projects are leaving.
The hermitage barcelona
also because of the podeites.
The grand prix of cataluña at the momelo circuit
is also threatening
to leave the enlargements in the prat of llobregat,
the famous big casino
for which we have been processed the budgets
that would provide so many jobs.
Catalonia is no longer
the economic engine that it was in its day,
not from spain but from europe.
Is it no longer that fourth region?
as a power in europe?
So uh,
something wrong will have been done by independence.
That's why I always say
that independence is independence.
That's the worst thing that could have happened to Catalonia,
isn't it?